ja so wird darf
wollte habe ich 27 europäische
staatsoberhäupter gefragt ob die ukraine
ein nato-mitglied wird ich habe sie ganz
direkt gefragt alle haben angst
sie antworten nicht
wir haben aber keine angst
wir haben angst von nichts
wir haben keine angst bei der unser land
verteidigen wir haben keine angst vor
russland wir haben keine angst mit
russland zu sprechen wir haben keine
angst alle themen anzusprechen
sicherheitsgarantien für unser land wir
haben keine angst über den neutralen
status zu sprechen wir sind jetzt kein
nato mitglied
wir sagen aber auch welche garantien wir
dabei haben und das allerwichtigste
welche staaten ganz konkret werden uns
diese garantien geben
ich bleibe in der hauptstadt meine
familie bleibt ebenfalls in der ukraine
meine kinder sind in der ukraine
meine familie sind keine verräter sie
sind ukrainische staatsbürger
wo sie sich aber gerade befinden habe
ich kein recht sie sagen anhand
informationen die uns vorliegen hat der
feind nicht als ziel nummer eins
bezeichnet meine familie ist ziel nummer
zwei sie wollen die ukraine vernichten
politisch indem sie dem staatsoberhaupt
vernichten
leider haben wir heute schon
137 helden verloren
das sind unsere bürger davon sind zehn
offiziere 316 sind verletzt
auf unserer schlangen insel haben die
helden dass bis zum letzten moment
verteidigt
alle
grenzschützer sind helden haft gestorben
aber sie haben nicht aufgegeben
werden
das leben die ukraine geopfert hat